preserving economic interest requires
trading and working with governments
like for example China that violate
human rights and yeah there are some who
would say well you can't do both you
can't go and talk to the Chinese about
stabilizing the global economy and the
steps that we want them to take two to
help us deal with obviously a an
existential economic crisis and at the
same time lecture them about their
treatment of dissidents for prisoners or
the Falin gone or Tibetans or what have
you I don't think that's right i think
that the united states and countries
like china work together on economic
matters because it's in their mutual
interest to do so i don't think china or
any other country works with us on those
issues to do us a flavor they do it
because it's in their interest to do so
as well so i don't think we damaged
ourselves diplomatically if we stand up
for our principles so long as we do it
in a intelligent way and that's the
challenge of diplomacy it's it's doing
more than one thing at one time and any
secretary of state or any president who
is up to the enormous challenge of those
jobs should be able to do that and I
also think that it's unrealistic to
think that that we can simply drop those
issues you know you can go into a
meeting with the Chinese and say you
know what we just can't afford to raise
the case of that dissident I can't
afford to lecture them about the poor
Tibetans because we've got to save the
global economy and then three months
later something awful is going to happen
in Tibet and guess what the United
States government is going to have to
say something about it because it would
be politically impossible not to
and then the Chinese having seen the
pattern of silence become even more
upset they'll say where does that come
from we thought you weren't talking to
us about that stuff anymore and the
diplomatic costs are even greater so I
think for you know realistic diplomatic
reasons it's better just to be
principled and consistent and send the
message out to every country that we
work with around the world you know
that's just part of doing business with
the United States that we're going to
raise those issues because it's who we
are it's what we believe
I don't know about self-determination
but sovereignty state sovereignty is
often used as an argument against
intervening to stop human rights abuses
and it's a complicated set of arguments
but certainly in cases where you have
extreme violence against civilians the
threat or reality of mass killing of
genocide I believe and in fact the
United Nations has adopted a principle
of responsibility to protect to deal
with those situations that if a state is
failing in its responsibility to protect
its own people from those kinds of
abuses then the rest of the world has a
responsibility to step in in whatever
way may be effective now what if we're
talking about less extreme violations of
human rights torture were newspapers
being closed down or people being in
prison because of because they're
expressing their views you know I think
very few people argue that those cases
merit military intervention invading a
country to take down its government but
there are other tools that I think are
appropriate to use to pressure countries
to change their behavior partly because
it's the right thing to do partly
because there are legal obligations
being violated when governments violate
human rights in those ways and partly
because we have a self interest in as
Americans in building a world in which
governments treat their people better a
lot of reasons for that so so I don't
think that sovereignty is an absolute
bar to one country or one group of
people promoting human rights beyond
their political borders
the United States can't be an effective
champion of Human Rights anywhere if
it's generally seen around the world as
a violator of human rights and so when
the bush administration was not just
engaging the justifying practices like
torture and disappearing people in
secret prisons and long-term detention
without charge it was very difficult not
impossible interestingly but difficult
for the United States to effectively
urge other countries not to do those
things i do think although I'm critical
of some of the things that the Obama
administration has done that that he has
gone a long way towards not just
eliminating those practices but
convincing the world that they're being
eliminated I I think this is actually a
moment perhaps a rare moment when the
United States government and
particularly the president has a lot of
moral credibility to go to the world and
champion an end to torture and they are
trials for everybody and freedom of the
press and freedom of speech that moment
may not last but we do have a moment
like that now and it's important that it
be used effectively analyzing
technology can be used to suppress human
rights and to facilitate human rights
that's always been the case there's
never been one technology that is
beneficial only to one side in that
struggle so governments like China and
Iran can use the internet to monitor the
their peoples communication to try to
identify dissidents and go after them
individually but of course campaigners
for democracy and human rights can also
use these technologies as we saw in Iran
to get around government restrictions on
speech and it's a tug-of-war between the
dark side of the Internet and the good
side and there's a lot that the United
States can do to to help the good side
win in that fight for example there are
really interesting technologies being
developed that allow people to
communicate privately to defeat
surveillance and to defeat censorship um
programs that can be downloaded by folks
in Iran and China and Burma and Vietnam
and it's something that we've asked the
US government to to fund and and support
there's also a very interesting and
ambiguous role played by American
technology companies like Google and
Yahoo and Cisco these are the companies
that develop these liberating
technologies that dissidents in Iran and
trying to use but they've also sometimes
partnered with the government's to give
them the technology they use to suppress
dissent they've censored their own
content sometimes and so helping these
companies figure out what their
responsibilities are when there are
operating in dictatorships and backing
them up when they have to stand up to
those governments is a really important
challenge for the 21st
you